allez on termine en beauté avec rien de
moins qu'un noble messieurs dames le
comte Dracula en personne comme tous les
vampires en général ce brave homme
présente tous les signes de la
porphyriie et notamment d'une de ses
formes rares la porphyriie
eritropoyétique les porphyries sont des
maladies génétiques du sang causé par un
déficit d'enzyme et caractérisé par
l'accumulation dans l'organisme de
substances appelées porphyine ce qui
donne une liste de symptômes assez
troublantes écoutez plutôt une
éricrodonciie les dents poussent
anormalement ce déformes prennent une
coloration rougeâtre avec en plus les
gencifs qui se rétractent ce qui
renforce l'impression que les dents sont
très longues une photodermatose au
contact du soleil la peau se couvre de
cloqu avec des sensations de brûlure qui
poussent les patients à vivre dans la
pénombre une anémie c'est-à-dire un
manque d'hémoglobine qui donne au
malades un teint très pâle et dont on
raconte qu'elle était traitée à l'époque
en leur faisant boire du sang espèce de
transfusion Old School mais qui marche
pas très bien la porphyrie entraîne
aussi une croissance anormale des poils
des cheveux et des ongles ce qui
correspond en tout point à la
description de Dracula dans le rom
original deobam staler pour finir sachez
qu'il est contreindiqué au patients
atteint de porphyie de manger de l'ail
parce que ça aggrave les symptômes